[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
guten Abend die Gaspreise steigen rapide
die Angst der Politik vor Bürgern die
ihre Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlen können
offenbar auch der Bundeskanzler
jedenfalls hatte heute das Gefühl dass
er am Mittag lieber selbst die eilig
beschlossene Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf
Erdgas verkünden wollte von 19 auf 7
Prozent nur 104 Sekunden dauerte seine
Erklärung Tenor wir tun was sofort
danach brach der streitlos ob diese
Steuersenkung nun eine echte Entlastung
bedeutet oder falscher Anreize setzt
Christiane hübscher aus Berlin
die Gaszähler Rennen gnadenlos und die
Bundesregierung versucht gegenzuhalten
ein neuer Beschluss Olaf Scholz macht es
kurz rund der mit der Mehrwertsteuer von
19 auf 7 Prozent und das nicht nur für
die Umlage sondern für die gesamte
Gasrechnung der mäßigte
Mehrwertsteuersatz wird so lange gelten
wie die gastbeschaffungsumlage erhoben
werden wird also bis zum 31 März 2024
mit diesem Schritt entlasten wir die
gastkunden insgesamt deutlich stärker
als die Mehrbelastung die durch die
Umlagen entsteht es gäbe jetzt viele
Nachfragen aber die sind nicht erlaubt
heute und so beginnt das große Rechnen
ein Single-Haushalt mit teurem
neukundentarif spart durch die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung im Schnitt etwa
132 Euro im Jahr zahlt aber im Gegenzug
etwa 130 Euro gasumlage
bei einem Vier-Personen-Haushalt bringt
die Steuersenkung im Jahr etwa 528 Euro
während die gasumlage für 518 Euro
Belastung sorgt
gasumlage und Mehrwertsteuersenkung zwei
politische Maßnahmen die sich praktisch
gegenseitig aufheben Kritik dafür von
Ökonomen finanziell macht das keinen
großen Unterschied aber es schafft mit
zusätzlichen Bürokratie man muss die
gasumlage berechnen die muss ausgewiesen
werden die Mehrwertsteuer muss verändert
werden die Unternehmen müssen das
anpassen da fragt man sich ist dieser
bürokratische Aufwand wirklich notwendig
wenn unterm Strich letztlich nicht bis
wenig verändert seit Wochen ruft die
Politik zum Energiesparen auf der
heutige Beschluss wirkt er auf manchen
seltsamen widersprüchlich einer
allgemeine Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer
ist erstmal nur eine neue fossile
Subvention die Erdgas günstiger macht
was wir aber ja brauchen ist
Preissignale sind Preissignale die eben
auch Haushalte die die Industrie eben
auch Anreizen weniger energievoll zu
verbrauchen Olaf Scholz dürfte gestern
einen Vorgeschmack auf den Herbst
bekommen haben einen Bürgerdialog im
brandenburgischen Neuruppin viele hier
in lautst versorge übersteigende Preise
linke und AFD mobilisieren bereits für
Proteste auch die heutige Entscheidung
reicht ihnen nicht den Unternehmen die
Mittelstand den Handwerker nutzt diese
Senkung überhaupt nichts weil die müssen
die Gasanlage im vollen Zügen bezahlen
müssen es durchreichen müssen es
weiterleiten also von daher ist das
keine Entlastung diese
Mehrwertsteuersenkung ist nur ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Stein wenn auch
richtig aber sie kann überhaupt nicht
das ausgleichen was aktuell an
Verteuerung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ansteht das scheint auch dem
Kanzler klar er verspricht ein drittes
Entlastungspaket für den Herbst Details
würden gerade besprochen
im ukraine-konflikt gab es heute einen
zaghaften diplomativversuch in wiff dem
alten Lemberg traf sich der ukrainische
Präsident selensky mit
UN-Generalsekretär goutherisch und dem
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan die UNO
und die Türkei hatten ja schon beim
Export von Getreide aus ukrainischen
Häfen vermittelt nun sollte es auch
darum gehen die Lage rund um das von
Russland besetzte Atomkraftwerk in
saporigia zu entspannen allein der mit
dem man darüber eigentlich hätte reden
müssen Wladimir Putin saß nicht mit am
Tisch und so blieb es bei Appellen das
Gelände rund ums Atomkraftwerk müsse
entmilitarisiert werden forderte der UNO
Generalsekretär Russland aber hatte
einen Abzug seiner Truppen aus der
Politiker schon vor dem dreiergipfel
ausgeschlossen Henna Hebestreit
berichtet für uns aus der Ukraine
es ist das Ende einer Dienstreise von
der sich der Reisende sicher mehr
versprochen hat der türkische Präsident
Erdogan war nach Lemberg gekommen und
vielleicht mit einem diplomatischen
Erfolg nach Hause zu fahren doch sein
Gastgeber wurde mir selensky hatte mit
klarer Geste am Grab gefallener Soldaten
gezeigt euer Opfer darf nicht vergeben
sein weshalb man sich über die Chancen
der Vermittlungsbemühungen Erdogans in
der Ukraine auch keine Illusion machte
die Ukraine bereitet gerade eine
Gegenoffensive vor Territorium
zurückerobern und Russland braucht vor
den September Wahlen dort auch einen
sichtbaren militärischen Erfolg nach
sechs Monaten Kampf
immerhin haben die Verhandlungen ergeben
dass die Regierung in Kiew am Abkommen
über den ukrainischen Getreideexport
festhalten will in den letzten Wochen
konnten mehr als 20 beladene Frachter
ablegen
Korridor für den Weizen Export
funktioniert viele Schiffe die seit
Kriegsbeginn hier festlagen können
fahren andere kommen rein
das Weizen exportabkommen von Istanbul
funktioniert also und wird von den
enttäuschten Unterhändlern in Lemberg
als Blaupause beschworen dass sich die
Konfliktparteien doch noch aufeinander
zu bewegen könnten
wir haben die Möglichkeiten ausgelotet
wie die positive Atmosphäre des
istanbul-abkommens zu einem dauerhaften
Frieden führen könnte
ein schwerer Brocken sind dabei die
Gespräche über die gespannte Lage rund
um das Atomkraftwerk saborissia wo immer
wieder geschossen wird und sich Russland
und die Ukraine gegenseitig vorwerfen
mit einer atomaren Katastrophe zu
spielen
die Anlage dafür keinerlei militärische
Zwecke missbraucht werden stattdessen
brauchen wir dringend eine Einigung das
saporizia als rein zivile Einrichtung
genutzt und die Sicherheit der Region
garantiert wird
Moskau hatte zuvor abgelehnt seine
Soldaten von den Kraftwerk
zurückzuziehen die Ukraine beschwört die
Gefahr die davon ausgeht
unakzeptabel das Russland die Welt an
den Rand einer nuklearen Katastrophe
bringt wir unterstützen die Bemühungen
der Vereinten Nationen Experten der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde über
unser Territorium nach saporicia zu
schicken
in der Umgebung des Kraftwerks verlassen
Sie sich nicht mehr auf den Erfolg
solcher Verhandlungen wie heute in
Lemberg sie üben für den Fall der Fälle
schon vier Tage nach dem russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine am 28 Februar
übernehmen Putins Truppen die Kontrolle
über das Gebiet rund um das
Kernkraftwerk saporizia in einer Nacht
Anfang März gibt es kurze Kämpfe um die
Atomanlage auf dem Gelände bricht ein
Brand aus erhöhte Radioaktivität wird
nicht gemessen seither steht das AKW
unter russischer Kontrolle es kommt
immer wieder zu Beschuss für den sich
beide Seiten gegenseitig verantwortlich
machen Christian Kirsch mit den Fakten
über ein Kernkraftwerk mitten im
Kriegsgebiet das Kernkraftwerk saporizia
ist das leistungsstärkste Kernkraftwerk
Europas seine sechs Kraftwerksblöcke
erzeugen zusammen eine Leistung von 5,7
Gigawatt derzeit sind wahrscheinlich
zwei Blöcke in Betrieb
es liegt im Südosten der Ukraine am
Fluss nipro und ist von existenzieller
Bedeutung für die Stromversorgung der
Ukraine seit März ist das
Kraftwerksgelände von russischen Truppen
besetzt auf dem Gelände sollen sich
seither rund 400 russische Soldaten
aufhalten während die Anlage weiterhin
von ukrainischem Personal betrieben und
beaufsichtigt wird offenbar nutzt die
russische Armee das Kraftwerksgelände
als Kommandoposten und zur Lagerung von
Nachschub und Munition ein Verstoß gegen
die Genfer Konvention
es gibt Berichte über ukrainische
partisanenangriffe auf russisches
Militär auf dem Gelände des Kraftwerks
Anfang August wurde das Gelände
beschossen was zum Ausfall einer
Hochspannungsleitung führte daraufhin
wurde einer der Reaktorblöcke
heruntergefahren
ein Herunterfahren der Reaktorblöcke ist
nur möglich bei kontinuierlicher
Stromversorgung da die Brennstäbe
permanent gekühlt werden müssen die
Stromversorgung des Kraftwerks ist also
von essentieller Bedeutung um die
Kühlkreisläufe in Gang zu halten nur so
lassen sich die Brennstäbe kontrollieren
bislang konnte die Stromversorgung
aufrecht erhalten werden
und aus Hamburg zugeschaltet ist uns
jetzt Heinz Metall Atomexperte von
Greenpeace schönen guten Abend
schönen guten Abend auch herr Michael
das Kriegshandlungen rund um einen
Kernkraftwerke gefährlich sind kann man
sich leicht vorstellen warum fahren die
Ukraine das Kraftwerk eigentlich nicht
einfach runter und schalten damit die
Gefahrenquelle aus
ja die Gefahrenquelle lässt sich
tatsächlich auch nicht so einfach
ausschalten weil auch ein abgeschalteter
Reaktor noch jahrelang gekühlt werden
muss und wenn es tatsächlich über die
Netzversorgung eine
eine Gefahr gibt dass die
Stromversorgung nicht aufrechterhalten
wird dann kann es durchaus Sinn machen
einen Reaktor zumindest im Betrieb zu
halten und so auch eine Eigenversorgung
durch einen Reaktor für die anderen
sechs Blöcke auf Bestand zu haben wir
haben ja bestanden verstanden dass es
extrem wichtig für das Funktionieren von
Reaktoren ist dass die Stromversorgung
funktioniert die Stromleitung zum zu
diesem Atomkraftwerk ist allerdings
schon mehrfach beschädigt worden ist das
eigentlich die größte Gefahr
das ist eine sehr große Gefahr es gibt
mehrere Leitungen also es besteht immer
noch eine
750.000 Volt Leitung und noch eine
330.000 Volt Leitung wenn alle gekappt
werden würden würde das wirklich eine
sehr kritische Situation ergeben es gibt
dann noch die Notstromdiesel die für
einen beschränkten Zeitraum versorgen
könnten aber in der Kriegssituation ist
die Frage ob das alles wirklich auch so
funktioniert und ob es diese Ergebnisse
und dann ist da ja noch der Faktor
Mensch man kann sich das ja eigentlich
kaum vorstellen wie die ukrainische
Belegschaft da bewacht von russischen
Soldaten vermutlich bewaffneten
russischen Soldaten dieses Atomkraftwerk
steuern was bedeutet diese psychische
Belastung eigentlich für die Sicherheit
des Kraftwerks
dies viel größer als man normalerweise
glaubt es zeigt sich das schwere Unfälle
dadurch passieren dass ein vielleicht
kleiner Fehler in der Anlage aber durch
einen Bedienfehler erst eskaliert ist
man hat ja nicht direkt in der Anlage
von der Warte aus Blick auf den Reaktor
sondern man hat nur Instrumente und und
sage ich mal
Beleuchtungen die einfach ein
Interpretation dann erfordern und zum
Beispiel das schwere Unfall von Frieden
als Island Harrisburg ist auch dadurch
passiert dass die Mannschaft das nicht
richtig interpretieren konnte was ich
wirklich im Reaktor abspielt und wenn
man jetzt eine Mannschaft hat die der
dich unter Stress ist dann kann man
nicht erwarten dass die hier alles
richtig macht dass der reakt auch
richtig gewartet ist das heißt diese
Bestandteile für einen schweren Unfall
Defizite in der Anlage und Bedienfehler
die haben wir beide vorliegen das heißt
doch unabhängig von der Kriegssituation
ist dort ein sehr brisanter sehr
gefährlicher Reaktorbetrieb bei den
Gesprächen heute in life ging es ja
darum einer internationalen
Beobachtermission Zugang zu der Anlage
zu gewähren abgesehen davon dass
Russland einen solchen Zugang ja bislang
verweigert was könnte denn eine solche
Mission wenn sie denn zustande käme
bringen
prinzipiell braucht es eine
entmillatarisierung bzw ein Ende der
Kampfhandlungen in einem größeren Umfeld
wenn das nicht direkt gelingt machen
schon Abkommen einen Sinn so wie wir das
bene getreideabkommen gesehen haben hier
wäre es aber zu kurz gegriffen nur der
internationalen Atomenergieorganisation
Zutritt zu verschaffen weil jedoch sehr
Russland nahe ist Russland ist der
größte Atomkraft Hersteller weltweit und
insofern bräuchte es tatsächlich eine
UN-Mission die auch Militärexperten und
auch vielleicht unabhängige Kraftwerke
Experten zu dem Gelände hinlässt
letztlich führt nichts dran vorbei das
Russland das Atomkraftwerk an die
Ukraine zurückgibt danach sieht es im
Moment leider noch nicht aus danke Heinz
mital Atomexperte von Greenpeace
Deutschland vielen Dank nach Hamburg
einen Live-Blog mit den aktuellen
Geschehnissen in der Ukraine finden sie
auf ZDF heute.de und in der ZDF heute
App
und wir bleiben noch beim
ukraine-konflikt von Russland keine
Signale zu Entspannung damit beginnen
die Nachrichten von Gundula Gause
russland hat drei Kampfflugzeuge in
seiner Ostsee in Exklave Kaliningrad
verlegt als so wörtlich zusätzliche
Maßnahme zur strategischen Abschreckung
die drei Abfangjäger mit 31 sind mit
neuen luftbodenraketen ausgestattet die
zehn Mal schneller als der Schall
fliegen können und eine Reichweite von
2000 Kilometern haben offenbar eine
drogede gegenüber der NATO
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat in einem
Telefonat mit israels Ministerpräsident
Lapid seine Empörung über die
holocaustäußerung von Palästinenser
Präsident Abbas zum Ausdruck gebracht
laut Regierungssprecher Hebestreit habe
Scholz betont dass er jeden Versuch den
Holocaust zu leugnen oder zu
relativieren scharfe Urteile aber es
Aussagen seien für ihn persönlich und
die gesamte Bundesregierung unerträglich
und völlig inakzeptabel abas hatte das
Vorgehen Israels gegen Palästinenser mit
dem Holocaust verglichen
vorerst keine Ergebnisse hat ein von der
EU geleitetes Krisentreffen im Konflikt
zwischen Serbien und dem Kosovo gebracht
der EU-Außenbeauftragte Borrell erklärte
anschließend er gebe nicht auf Kosovos
Regierungschef Kurti und Serbiens
Präsident Vucic äußerten sich nicht zu
den umstrittenen Fragen der Anerkennung
und zu Grenzkonflikten das Kosovo
beansprucht seit 1999 Eigenständigkeit
Belgrad betrachtet die Region als
abtrünnige Provinz
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat die
Bestätigung der Masern Impfpflicht durch
das Bundesverfassungsgericht begrüßt
eine Masernerkrankung sei
lebensgefährlich die Karlsruher Richter
haben die seit März 2020 geltende
Nachweispflicht einer masernimmunität
für betreute Kinder bestätigt damit
dürfen Kitas und Tagesmütter auch
künftig Kinder nur dann aufnehmen wenn
diese nachweislich gegen Masern geimpft
sind oder sie bereits hatten die Klagen
von vier Familien wurden zurückgewiesen
die Ständige Impfkommission empfiehlt
seit heute Nachmittag nun eine vierte
Impfung gegen das Coronavirus für
Menschen ab 60 auch Kinder ab fünf
Jahren sollen sich ruhig ein weiteres
Mal impfen lassen wenn sie ein erhöhtes
Risiko für einen schweren Verlauf haben
gerade für die verspätete Empfehlung der
Impfung von Kindern war die STIKO im
letzten Winter scharf kritisiert worden
immer mehr Eltern treibt die Sorge um
dass ihre Kinder longkowit bekommen
könnten es ist eine Angst die sich mit
zuverlässigen Zahlen nicht belegen lässt
aber Einzelfälle gibt es durchaus Petra
otto hat sich auf die Suche gemacht
eigentlich wäre sie jetzt mit ihrer
Mutter in der Türkei aber Emma schwarz
elf Jahre ist für Urlaub einfach zu
schwach sie erkrankte in dem März an
Corona kein schlimmer Verlauf die
Beschwerden sie kommen erst danach und
gehen bisher einfach nicht mehr weg
das schlimmste ist eigentlich Herzrasen
und die Atemnot weil wenn ich dann
schlechte Luft bekommen dann bekomme ich
auch einfach Panik so kenne ich mich
eigentlich nicht dass ich eigentlich nur
im Bett liege und nach ein paar Metern
schon sagt mir ist es zu viel Roland
Elling kennt solche Fälle schon aber er
sieht sie bei Kindern ganz selten und
sie kriegen selbst in der Uniklinik das
Phänomen long-covid nicht richtig zu
fassen es ist ganz klar dass es da ist
es ist auch ganz klar dass es echt ist
sozusagen es ist bloß für uns ärztlich
und auch wissenschaftlich extrem
schwierig das zu messen indem es Sinne
dass wir keine Labor Parameter haben mit
denen wir das zeigen können auch alle
bildgebenden und funktionellen
Untersuchungen zeigen üblicherweise
keine Auffälligkeiten die Wissenschaft
hängt noch immer in der Luft kaum jemand
kennt sich aus es gibt keine einhellige
Behandlung kein Medikament und die
Familien stehen im Regen über Wochen
Monate man musste sich eigentlich selbst
drum kümmern man fühlt sich oft hilflos
dem Kind gegenüber
weil man gar keine Mittel hat oft zu
helfen
und ich glaube schon dass man dann immer
mal wieder auch was falsches sagt ja
aber man probiert es einfach immer
Emmas Kinderarzt schickt sie schließlich
nach Freiburg jetzt ist wenigstens klar
dass sie sonst nichts hat sie hat
longkowit in Freiburg forschen Sie an
den Langzeitfolgen von Corona und
veröffentlichen jetzt eine Studie mit
1.200 Teilnehmenden aus 340 Haushalten
sie vergleichen die die infiziert waren
mit Familienmitgliedern die kein Corona
hatten also nur exponiert waren
Erwachsene Jugendliche und Kinder und
man sieht bei den Kindern egal ob
Weiblein oder Männlein und auch egal ob
exponiert oder infiziert dass diese
Symptome hier fertig Probleme beim Atmen
Druck auf der Brust dass die bei Kindern
wirklich nur ganz selten ein Jahr nach
der Infektion auftreten unter longkowitz
so zeigt das Diagramm leiden vermehrt
weibliche Jugendliche und Erwachsene ob
er ausgelöst durch das Virus selbst oder
durch die schwierige pandemie-situation
daran müssen sie weiter forschen immer
hatte einfach Pech einer der ganz
wenigen extremen Fälle bei Kindern doch
die Aussichten dass sie bald wieder ganz
gesund wird sind gut das braucht eben
Zeit und sie braucht Geduld viel Geduld
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und
diagonalarm
deutsche Unternehmen suchen dringend
Nachwuchs in Sachen Ausbildung schlägt
der deutsche Industrie und
handelskammertag Alarm viele
Ausbildungsplätze sind noch unbesetzt zu
viele Valerie Haller Azubis werden also
dringend gesucht in welchen Branchen vor
allem das zieht sich durch ganz viele
Branchen sogar die Industrie ist
betroffen die bislang ja eigentlich als
sichere Bank galt laut dem Deutschen
Industrie- und handelskammertag war es
noch nie so schwierig Azubis zu finden
das ist auch eine Folge von Corona weil
durch die kontaktbeschränkungen etwa die
Berufsberatung deutlich schwieriger
wurde das wird besser was aber bleibt
ist die demografische Entwicklung
Deutschlands Unternehmen fehlt der
Nachwuchs und so gibt es immer häufiger
einfach keine Bewerbungen laut einer
DIHK-Umfrage konnten über 40 Prozent der
befragten Betriebe vergangenes Jahr
nicht alle Ausbildungsplätze besetzen
ein Rekord und jede dritte von diesen
Firmen erhielt keine einzige Bewerbung
im stärksten betroffen ist das gastgewer
gefolgt von Transport und Logistik und
der Industrie die Folgen des
azubi-mangels sind für viele Betriebe
schwerwiegen kürzere Öffnungszeiten
längere Wartezeiten für Kunden Aufträge
werden abgelehnt Unternehmen lassen sich
daher einiges einfallen um Azubis
anzulocken flexible Arbeitszeitmodelle
moderne IT-Technik finanzielle Anreize
einige Branchen können den Mangel besser
wegstecken als andere aber große Ziele
wie die Energie- und Verkehrswende
Digitalisierung und der Bau von neuen
Wohnungen sind laut Bildungsexperten
ohne mehr Nachwuchs kaum zu bewältigen
die Politik wird sich etwas einfallen
lassen vielen Dank valerina Frankfurt
in Südeuropa hat lang ersehnter Regen
teilweise Entspannung in die
waldbrandgebiete gebracht die
Ausbreitung der Brände in der spanischen
urlaubsregierung Valencia ist laut
Behörden gestoppt viele Orts sein die
Flammen erloschen auch das Feuer im
portugiesischen Naturschutzgebiet Cera
da istrela konnte unter Kontrolle
gebracht werden schwere Gewitter mit
stürmen haben in Frankreich Italien und
Österreich zugleich mindestens zwölf
Menschen das Leben gekostet und auch für
Teile Bayerns warnt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor extrem ergiebigem
Dauerregen
zu den European Championships da hat
Konstanze klosterhalfen vor wenigen
Minuten als erste deutsche EM-Gold über
5000 Meter gewonnen die 25-Jährige
setzte sich in Münchner Olympiastadion
deutlich vor Jasmin Chan aus der Türkei
und Irish MCN aus Großbritannien durch
und bei der Schwimm-EM in Rom hat einen
Tag nach ihrem Sieg im Mixed synchron
springen Tina punzel zusammen mit Lena
Henschel auch den Wettbewerb von 3 m
Brett gewonnen mit diesem zweieinhalb
Auerbach Salto gehechtet holten sie die
siebte Goldmedaille für das deutsche
Team bei den Europameisterschaften Gold
also für punzel und Henschel klar vor
den Siegerinnen aus Italien und Schweden
mitten in den em-erfolgen hat der
deutsche Schwimmverband Bundestrainer
Lutz Buschkow mit sofortiger Wirkung
freigestellt damit reagiert der DSV auf
Vorwürfe Buschkow Farbe nicht an der
Aufklärung möglichen Missbrauchs
mitgewirkt dies müsse geklärt werden so
der DSV man habe bislang aber keine
Hinweise dass die Vorwürfe gegen
Buschkow zutreffen
zuvor hatte der ehemalige Weltklasse
Wasserspringer Jan Hempel in der ARD von
jahrelanger sexueller Gewalt eines
früheren Trainers berichtet Werner
langer soll sich an ihm vergangen haben
seit seinem elften Lebensjahr zeitweise
täglich auch während Olympische Spiele
darüber habe er Hempel im DSV berichtet
alle hätten geschwiegen lange hatte sich
2001 das Leben genommen
das vollkornmuseum in Essen feiert
seinen hundertsten Geburtstag und schaut
dabei zurück auf die eigene Geschichte
auf den Museumsgründer der die Kunst der
Expressionisten erkannte und förderte
und auf den von den Nazis eingesetzten
Direktor der ihre Gemälde als entartet
wieder aus dem Museum rauswarf entdeckt
verfilmt gefeiert heißt die Ausstellung
mit inzwischen wiederbeschafften
Greatest Hits von Kokoschka Nolde und
Ernst Ludwig Kirchner Kerstin Edinger
durfte schon mal gucken
überreizte Farben ein starker
Pinselstrich
die Werke der Expressionisten geben
nichts natürliches wieder sondern das
was den Künstlern auf der Seele brennt
wild und herausfordernd feiern sie den
freien Umgang mit Form und Farbe
[Musik]
ein rotes Pferd mit lila Mähne
expressive Körper manche Zeitgenossen im
frühen 20 Jahrhundert überfordert das
die Expressionisten waren Rebellen des
Bildes die waren Jungen aufführerisch
die wollten aufs neues erreichten es war
neue
Sehgewohnheiten die man so noch nicht
kannte er war von der neuen
Kunstrichtung fasziniert Karl Ernst
Osthaus industriellen Sohn und Begründer
der volkswagensammlung der
Expressionismus stand für ihn für
Aufbruch und moderne er unterstützte die
Künstler sammelte ihre Werke von Anfang
an Franz Marc ein guter Freund Oskar
Kokoschka stellte zum ersten Mal bei ihm
aus auch Paula Modersohn-Becker eine
seiner Entdeckungen
nach seinem toten 1921 ging die Sammlung
von Hagen in die Nachbarstadt Essen
wurde dort in seinem Sinne weitergeführt
doch dann die Zäsur die Macht Übernahme
der Nationalsozialisten sie diffamieren
den Expressionismus sehen ihn als
entartet an zu unnatürlich zu aufmüpfig
ist Ihnen diese Kunstform und 1.400
Werke aus der volkswagensammlung landen
auf diesen Verkaufslisten sie werden
beschlagnahmt und ins Ausland veräußert
und dann ist Anfang 34 ein strammer
Nationalsozialist Museumsdirektor
geworden der unter anderem selbst daran
beteiligt war dass diese große
beschlagnahmeaktion unter diesem
schrecklichen Begriff entartete Kunst
durchgeführt wurde das volkswagen ist
also da als Institution gleichzeitig
Opfer mit seiner Sammlung aber
gleichzeitig auch Täter
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist die
Sammlung nicht mehr das was sie war doch
das Museum Folkwang wagt den Neuanfang
kauft viele hochkarätige Gemälde zurück
und das bis heute
stolz präsentiert man die
Expressionisten nun in einer Sonderschau
zum hundertsten Geburtstag des Museums
es ist der späte Triumph einer
außergewöhnlichen Sammlung deren Höhen
und Tiefen man hier miterleben kann
[Musik]
ab diesem Samstag ist die Ausstellung in
Essen zu sehen wir empfehlen Ihnen jetzt
noch Maybrit Illner die mit ihren Gästen
über teure Energie diskutiert mit der
Frage entlasten sparen rationieren
und gegen 0:45 Uhr melde ich mich wieder
mit unserem heute journal Update uns
beide gibt es morgen wieder einen
schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend in den nächsten 36 Stunden
wird dieses Tief hier über Oberitalien
weiter nordostwärts ziehen es bringt
Unwetter mit in Italien und kräftigen
Dauerregen in den Alpen aber auch bei
uns gleichzeitig zieht ein schnelles
tief weiter Richtung Schweden und dann
kommt von Nordwesten auch noch eine
kleine Kaltfront heran die bis Samstag
früh dann Deutschland schon zur Mitte
überquert haben war das ist also viel
los beim Wetter und besonders ergiebig
ist dieser Dauerregen am Alpenrand da
drohen dann wirklich Überschwemmungen
und auch Erdrutsche heute Nacht gibt es
auch Gewitter hier in Nordosten
Deutschlands und die Temperaturen sinken
in Berlin nicht unter 20 Grad deutlich
kühler wird es im Westen und auch im
Süden mit 14 bis 12 Grad und morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei 23 bis
30 Grad aber wird es am Mittelrhein am
wärmsten am Alpenrand werden dagegen
kaum 18 bis 22 Grad erreicht in dem
Dauerregen Schauer und Gewitter der
Nacht ziehen hier im Nordosten morgen
nordwärts raus dann wechseln Sonne und
Wolken miteinander ab bevor dann am
späten jeden Tag und Abend diese neue
kleine kaltfronter reinkommt einige
Regenschauer sind dazu beobachten und
dann gibt es diesen ganz ergiebigen
Dauerregen mit Gewittern durchsetzt der
vor allen Dingen die Alpenregion in Atem
halten wird auch am Samstag gewittert es
noch kräftig weiter danach beruhigt sich
das Wetter und wenn sie am Alpenrand
jetzt in den Dauerregen sitzen fragen
Sie sich wann ist es damit vorbei Anfang
der Woche und dann nimmt auch der
Unterschied zwischen den Tag und den
Nachttemperaturen wieder zu guten Abend